ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูนิดสวัสดีครับครูหญิง
สบายดีไหมครับสบายดีค่ะคุณนิคสบายดีนะคะ
สบายดีครับแล้วก็นักเรียนทุกคน
น่าจะสบายดี
ลืมสวัสดีนักเรียนอีกแล้ว
โอ๊ย
เรื่องอีกแล้วสวัสดีนักเรียนทุกคน
นักเรียน
แบบเน้นเนี่ยว่าทำเป็นถามว่านักเรียนทุก
คนน่าจะสบายดีผู้หญิงดูอีกแล้วว่าลืมผู้
หญิงหรือใจๆวะเองพรุ่งนี้ลืมสวัสดีตู้เคย
สวัสดีนักเรียนอีกแล้วแต่ก่อนที่จะลืมมาก
ไปกว่านี้ขอเขียนวันที่ก่อนนะฮะ
โอเคได้ๆดูอันนี้สิว่ามันจะดีขึ้นไหมนะฮะ
อ่ะคุณอีกวันนี้วันอะไรคะค่ะวันนี้วันพุธ
ครับ
เก็บยากนะวันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 15 ครับ
เดือนอะไรคะเดือนมิถุนายนถ้าเป็นเดือนที่
เชพ.ต.ต.อะไรคะดีผช
2565 ขับชัดปีคศอะไรคะปีคศ 2  022 ครับ
ค่ะตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงคะคุณนี้ตอนที่บ้าน
จึงที่นี่นะครับที่คุณนิคอยู่เนี่ยเวลา
8:00 น 37 นาทีครับตอนชั่นเอาติดตามเช้า
เนาะชายสา่ค่ะ
แล้วที่คุณนิครูหญิงอยู่แล้วครับกี่โมง
พี่คุยถึงอยู่ก็ 9 โมง 37 นาทีต่อแต่เช้า
เหมือนกันก็สายๆแล้วนะ 9:00 น
โอเคก็ตอนนี้เราอยู่ประเทศเดียวกันแต่
ต่างหูคนลาคนรัฐคนละที่เวลามันก็จะไม่
เหมือนกันไม่เหมือนกันทรายบางครั้งก็ f
งงเวลาเหมือนกันนะนายตัวลืมเวลาได้ไหมลืม
ได้ไหม
หรือ
ยูได้มั้ย
ก็ได้มั้งบางทีเราก็พูดได้นะว่าเหมือนจะ
ลืมว่าอ๋อเวลาที่นี่มันต้องเป็นเวลาอย่าง
นี้อ้อพูดถึงลืมผู้หญิงอย่าลืมนะครับ
เพราะว่าที่ทำอะไรนานเนี่ยเขาจะมีเปลี่ยน
เวลาด้วยนะตอนไหนเขาจะมีเคาน์เตอร์เขาจะ
เรียกว่าเป็นเหมือนกับช่วงแบบเค้าจะเรียก
ไม่เป็นพวกเหมือน Daylight  Saving ที่
เขาจะปรับเวลา 1 ชั่วโมงให้เร็วขึ้นให้
อาบน้ำมีอะน้ำหนักต้องระวังเพราะว่าน่าจะ
ใกล้ๆแล้ว
คุณนิดจำได้ว่าเขาจะมีเปลี่ยนช่วงเขาจะมี
เปลี่ยนช่วงประมาณตุลาคม
เห็นเขียนเมื่อ 2 เดือนที่แล้วเมื่อ
เมษายนใช่ก็คือตอนนี้ก็น่าจะเปลี่ยนแล้ว
เพราะว่าผู้หญิงก็จำได้ว่าเมื่อก่อนที่
ไทยกับอะหยังผู้หญิงอยู่นิวยอร์กใช่ไหม
นิวยอร์กเนี่ยมันจะห่างกันเนี่ย 12
ชั่วโมงแต่ตอนเนี้ยเหมือนเวลาเปลี่ยนไก่
กับนิวยอร์กเนี่ยห่างกัน 11 ชั่วโมงทาย
ใช่แบบนี้ล่ะครับชายมันก็จะเป็นที่เขา
เปลี่ยนที่เขาที่คุณนิดบอกมาเกี่ยวจะต้อง
ระวังเพราะว่าถ้ามันเร็วแล้วมันจะเปลี่ยน
ตอนกลางคืนนะคือถ้าจะไม่ที่ดาบตี 2 ปุ๊บ
เนี่ยเข็มมันจะเปลี่ยนละจ่ายก็คือ
ถ้าเกิดว่าไม่ได้ใช้โทรศัพท์เหมือนที่
เป็นแบบพวกสมาร์ทโฟนน่ะตัว iPhone เลยพวก
เนี้ยมันจะไม่ปรับเผื่อเวลาให้
เราถ้าเราไม่ทำเองอะเราอาจะลืมว่าอาจจะไป
ทำงานสาย 1 ชั่วโมงหรือไปเร็วกว่า 1
ชั่วโมงแบบเนี้ยใช่วางผู้หญิงเคยมีนัก
เรียนที่เขาเรียนตอนประมาณเดือนช่วงเดือน
ตุลาคมหรืออะไรสักอย่างเนี่ยอ่ะค่ะแล้ว
เขาก็นัดเราว่าอ้ะ 18:00 นแต่เขาใน
อเมริกาก็คือ 6:00 นผู้หญิงก็มานั่งรอ
18:00 นแล้วก็ทำไมนักเรียนไม่มาไม่มา
ผ่านไปครึ่งชั่วโมงคิดสงสัยนักเรียนยัง
ไม่ตื่นมั้งก็ไม่ส่งข้อความมาทำไมพอเวลา
ผ่านไปถึงประมาณ 19:00 นนักเรียนก็ส่งข้อ
ความมาวะขอโทษลืมว่าอเมริกาเนี่ยเปลี่ยน
เวลาอยู่แล้วใช่ๆจริงๆมันเป็นหลายประเทศ
เลยนะที่เปลี่ยนเวลาแบบเยอะเราก็คนหลายคน
ก็จะลืมพี่สาวคุณเอ็กซ์ก็ลืมบางครั้งแล้ว
กับเอ้อมันเปลี่ยนเวลา
ใช่แล้วลืมมั้ย
ลืมไหมคนดีก็ไม่ลืมเพราะว่าโทรศัพท์คุณ
นิคมันเปลี่ยนแบบอัตโนมัติงานคุณนี้ก็จะ
ยิ่งคุณนี้ก็จะไม่ใส่นาฬิกาข้อมือคุณนี้
จะดูดูเวลาในโทรศัพท์มันก็มันก็จะง่าย
เพราะว่าคุณนี้ก็เขียนให้เราเลยใช่มันจะ
เปลี่ยนให้เลยเราก็ ok ดีแล้วใช่งั้นก็
แปลว่าคุณอีกก็ไม่ใช่คนที่ลืมอะไรง่ายๆ
ใช่ไหม
หัวเราะอะไรนะ
ชื่อแค่ครู Dexter บอกว่าไอ้เปลี่ยนเวลา
เนี่ยคุณดีก็ไม่ลืมได้เต็มตื่นล่ะคนในก็
ลืมบ่อย
คืออะไรบ้างก็โอ้ลืมก็ลืมหลายอย่างนะพูด
ถึงเรื่องเรื่องเวลาเนี่ยคุณดีกะจำได้เลย
ว่าปีที่แล้วอันเนี่ยลืมเปลี่ยนเวลาเพราะ
ว่า
ของของผู้นิดเนี่ยตอนนั้นไปหาเพื่อนที่
เสียเธอนั่นแล้วเสียเธอเนี่ยมันจะช้ากว่า
เมืองที่คุณนิคอยู่ 2 ชั่วโมงพรุ่งนี้ก็
บอกเพื่อนว่าเออๆเนี่ยเดี๋ยวเครื่องเนี่ย
จะไปถึงที่เสียโทเนี่ยเราลงเวลานี้นะแบบ
ประมาณ
เขาบอกว่าเนี่ยจะลงไปถึงเวลานี้ถ้าจะไม่
ถึง 11:00 นใช่ 11:00 นแล้วที่นี้
คุณนี้ก็บอกว่าเออแล้วก็หลังจากนั้น
เดี๋ยวสักครึ่งชั่วโมงก็มาก็ได้ขับรถมา
รับเครื่องก็บอก ok  ok ก็ได้แล้วที่นี้
คุณนิก้าจะเวลาถ้าเกิดว่าไปตามเมืองอื่นๆ
เนี่ยคุณนี้ก็จะตังค์แบบไม่ให้มันปรับ
อัตโนมัติ or ให้เราปรับเองยะหรอก็เรา
ปรับเองเพราะว่าคุณนี้ก็เคยมีปัญหาให้มัน
ปรับอัตโนมัติเราเมื่อก่อนที่คุณเคยบินไป
แถบเอเชียไปเที่ยวๆอย่างที่เคยบอกว่า
อินโดอินโดนีเซียที่เค้าจะมีเวลา 2 เวลา
แล้วมันชอบกลับเวลาเองแล้วคุณนี่กับงงว่า
เดินไป 5 นาทีเมื่อกี้ยังเวลานี้อีก 5
นาทีปรับไปเร็วกว่า 1 ชั่วโมงมันกลับไปมา
หาคุณนี้ก็เลยงงคุณนี้ก็เลยตั้งให้ปรับ
เองที่นี้เนี่ยคุณนี้ก็ไปถึงที่ CR เทอม
ใช่ไหมครับเพื่อมันก็ลงแล้วเทอมนี้ก็เออ
ถึงแล้วนะแต่เดี๋ยวจะไปไปคุยกับเพื่อนที่
สนามบินแป๊บนึงพอ 555 มีเพื่อนคุณนิคอีก
คนที่เขาว่าอยู่ที่เซียร์ Turn แล้วกำลัง
จะกลับประเทศไทยค่ะก็เลยบอกเพื่อนว่าเออ
เดี๋ยวเดี๋ยวแป๊บนึงแป๊บนึงจะไปคุยกับ
เพื่อนอีกคนนึงก่อนทรัพย์แป๊บ
13:00 น 13:00 นตรงค่อยมารับก็ได้ซึ่งก็
บอกขอคุยแป๊บเดียวทำไมให้ไปรับ 13:00 น
ใช่เพราะคุณถึง 11 โมงไม่ใช่เหรอใช่ใช่
คือบ่ก็เพื่อนเขาบอกเอ๊ะบ่ายโมงบ่ายโมง
ครึ่งหรอแต่เพื่อนคนนี้ก็ไม่ได้บอกเวลานะ
คือคุณด้วยกับเป็นคนทำเองเนี่ย 13:30 น
13:30 นประมาณนั้นน่ะมารับเพราะว่าจะไป
คุยกับเพื่อนอีกคนก่อนค่ะอันนี้ก็แบบ
เงียบๆแล้วก็บอกโอเคเขาก็ไม่ถามอะไรใช่
ไหมถามอะไรใช่คนด้วยก็เออมันโอเคแล้วเขา
โอเคคุณก็เอาคือเรื่องไปเจอเพื่อนแล้วก็
คุยคุยคุยกันแป๊บนึงเพื่อนคุณนิคนนั้นน่ะ
เขาก็ถามว่าอ้าวแล้วเพื่อนจะมารับปากกี่
โมงค่ะอันนี้ก็บอกก็เดี๋ยวใกล้จะมาแล้ว
เนี่ยคืนนี้ก็ดูเวลาว่าเธออีก 10 นาทีก็
จะถึงและเพราะว่าบอกให้มาบ่ายโมงประมาณ
13:30 นค่ะเพื่อนคู่นี้นะครับอ่าวเฮ้ย
เฮ้ย
ตอนนี้มัน 11 โมงกว่านะ
ก็คือด้วยก็ดูเวลาใหม่แล้วก็
เออมันเป็นเวลาของเมืองที่คุณด้วยกันอยู่
เครื่องบินมาใช่คุณด้วยกันลืมเปลี่ยนให้
มันช้าลง
ขึ้นตายแล้วทำยังไงคุณมีก็รีบโทรโทรมาบอก
ก็แล้วเฮ้ยบอกเวลาถีบเนี่ยออกมาหรือยัง
ช้าเราเพื่อนว่ายังไงคะแต่โชคดีว่าเพื่อน
คนนี้ก็บอกว่าเออก็คิดอยู่เหมือนกันว่า
ตอนแรกตอนแรกบอกให้มารับแบบครึ่งชั่วโมง
หลังจากเครื่องลงแล้วทำไมเปลี่ยนให้มัน
รับดับบ่ายโมงกว่าอีก 2 ชั่วโมงก็ครับ
ทำไมคุยอะไรกับคนอื่นนานหรอบอกแป๊บเดียว
แต่ก็คือโชคดีว่าเพื่อนคุณอีกนะเขาขับรถ
ออกมาละกันเขาก็คิดว่าคุณนี้อากาศน่าจะจำ
เวลาผิด
ก็จะกินว่าเขาก็รู้ว่าคุณนิดอยู่เมืองไหน
จะไหมเวลาปกติเนี่ยมันห่างกันกี่ชั่วโมง
เออใช่ๆแล้วคือคุณนี้ก็บอกว่าเออๆมาแล้ว
กันรีบมารีบมาจะเพื่อนก็โอเคใช่จบดีนะที่
เพื่อนเนี่ยเหมือนแบบ
ลิคจำเวลาผิดหรือเปล่านะเอ๊ยใช่คือเพื่อน
เพื่อนคุณนิกะห์หมอก็บอกนะว่าเนี่ย
เขาเตรียมเตรียมจากดูหนังเมืองกะว่าเออ
นิคบอกว่าอีกตั้ง 2 ชั่วโมงจะแบบนั่งเปิด
เน็ตลิปดูละครแล้วอ่ะ
ติดตั้ง 2 ชั่วโมงก็ดู 1 รอก็ได้นะใช่ดู
หาซีรีส์หาละครดูหรือหนังใน netflix เอา
ก็รักกันให้
ก็ดีนะค่ะไม่งั้นก็คุณนี้ก็นั่งอยู่สนาม
บินก็ต้องโทรจะก็ต้องรออยู่ดีใช่ไหมใช่
เราเมืองใหญ่รถก็ติดอีกแต่งชายโชคดีว่า
เพื่อนคุณมีกันนึกได้ว่าเออนี้มันน่าจะ
ลืมเวลาชื่อ
จบ
ผู้หญิงเคยลืมอะไรไหมถ้าเป็นเวลาเนี่ยไม่
ค่อยนะคะแต่ถ้าทดคือถ้าไปโทรศัพท์ผู้หญิง
เงี้ยเปลี่ยนอัตโนมัติอยู่แล้วแต่ถ้าปกติ
หรอเป็นคนลืมอะไรง่ายๆไหมคือคือเรื่อง
ชีวิตธรรมดาเนี่ยออกจากบ้านลืมก็คุยเล่า
เลยแล้วกันเป็นเรื่องที่เพิ่งเกิดล่าสุด
ก็คือผู้หญิงเนี่ยนัดจบเพื่อนนะคะเจอกัน
ที่สยามเฮอไม่ได้สยามเซ็นทรัลเวิลด์เจอ
กับเพื่อนที่เซ็นทรัลเวิลด์ใช่อ่าแล้วผู้
หญิงเนี่ยนัดเจอกับเพื่อนประมาณ 18:30 น
17:30 น 17:30 นโทรค่ะ man ตอนแม่ไม่
อยู่แล้วเลยอ่ะ 17:30 นแล้วก็คือผู้หญิง
ก็ออกจากบ้านประมาณ 4 โมงแล้วก็ไม่ๆนั่ง
BTS นะคะคือเจอกันที่สยามก่อนแต่จะไปที่
เซ็นทรัลเวิลด์คือเจอที่สยามแล้วก็เดินไป
เซ็นทรัลเวิลด์ไม่นั่ง BTS เพราะว่าขี้
เกียจก็เลยเรียกแร็พนั่งแกร๊บคล้ายๆ
แท็กซี่อ่ะค่ะก็รถติดมาก
[เพลง]
ดูผู้หญิงถึง Siam  17:30 นพอดีเลยแต่ว่า
เพื่อนเดินไปเซ็นทรัลเวิลด์แล้วเพราะ
เพื่อนถึงเร็วก็เลยบอกว่าโอเคเพื่อนไปรอ
ที่ Central  World เลยเดี๋ยวผู้หญิงถึง
สยามแล้วเดินไปแต่พอถึงสยามแล้วเนี่ยเรา
ก็คิดมันก็เริ่มหิวข้าวแล้วไงก็เลยนั่ง
มอเตอร์ไซค์เดินไปขึ้นมอเตอร์ไซค์
ก็บอกว่ามอเตอร์ไซค์นั่งจากสยามไป
เซ็นทรัลเวิลด์เนี่ย 4 มอเตอร์ไซค์ก็บอก
40 บาทเพราะผู้หญิงขึ้นมอเตอร์ไซค์ปุ๊บ
ผู้หญิงก็นึกขึ้นได้ว่าลืมกดเงิน
ที่กระเป๋าน่ะไม่มีเงิน 10 บาทก็ไม่มีคุณ
อีก 1 บาทพูด Siri เออแล้วได้มอเตอร์ไซค์
แล้วมอเตอร์ไซค์แล้วเนี่ยทำยังไงล่ะเมื่อ
คืนเนี่ยมีอยู่แค่นี้อ่ะมีกระเป๋าอยู่แค่
นั้นแล้วไม่มีเงินแล้วนั่งมอเตอร์ไซค์
แล้วก็คิดที่มอเตอร์ไซค์เนี่ยสแกนจ่ายได้
ไหมผู้หญิงก็เลยเอาชุดทำไงฉันยังไงทำไมก็
เลยโทรศัพท์ไปหาเพื่อนบอกว่าฮัลโหลช่วยมา
รอข้างหน้า Central  World ได้ไหมอ่ะขอ
ยืมเงิน 40 บาทจ่ายค่ามอเตอร์ไซค์
ก็โชคดีที่เพื่อนรู้ว่าผู้หญิงลงตรงไหนก็
เลยมารอแล้วผู้หญิงเป็นคนที่ลืมกดเงิน
บ่อยมาก
เหมือนเราก็ใช้ชีวิตกับการสแกนจ่ายให้ใช่
มันไม่ค่อยมันไม่ค่อยมีเงินสดเงินสดหน่อย
ค่ะแล้วเนาะใช่มันก็แก้มจ่ายได้หรือโอน
จ่ายได้แล้วมันก็เลยใช่คนนี้ก็เป็นเพราะ
ว่าอยู่ที่เวลาอยู่กรุงเทพฯก็จะจ่ายบัตร
เครดิตหรือโอนเงินให้เพื่อนหรือสแกนจ่าย
จะเป็นโค้ชใช่ก็มีคนนี้ก็เคยมีเหมือนเขา
ถ้าไม่มีเงินสดเราก็
แล้วก็
ไม่รู้จะทำยังไงคู่นี้ก็จะบอกนะว่าที่พี่
ขอแวะไป ATM ก่อนได้ไหม
พี่ก็คิดอย่างนั้นแหละแต่แบบคิดณ
เซ็นทรัลเวิร์ล ATM อยู่ตรงนั้น
เมื่อไหร่ก็แปลว่าอันนี้เป็นเรื่องที่ลืม
บ่อยมากนะคะแบบว่าลืมเช็คว่าตัวเองเนี่ย
ในกระเป๋าเนี่ยมีเงินไหมว่าแบบซื้อของที่
ฟุตบาทร้านอาหารที่นักเรียนเรียกว่าแบบ
Street  Food อ่ะก็แสกนคิวอาร์โค้ดจ่าย
ได้แล้วไงคะใช่ชายแต่ต้องมอเตอร์ไซค์แต่
มอเตอร์ไซค์เนี่ยมอเตอร์ไซค์ได้ไหมไม่รู้
ว่ะแต่คิดว่าบางคนนะบางคนให้นะเหมือนกับ
ว่าบางคนบอกว่าโอนเงินให้ก็ได้ค่ะ
คุณนี้ก็ยังไม่เคยนะแต่คนนี้คิดว่าเขาน่า
ฮะโอเค
จ่ายน่ารักอะก็เป็นเรื่องที่แบบว่าลืม
หรือว่าช่วงนี้ไม่รู้อร่อยอายุมากขึ้น
หรือเปล่าอะไรนิดๆหน่อยๆก็ลืมๆพอ 20 ผัด
นะแล้วก็เขาคงแก่แล้วเนาะ
ว่าแบบเพื่อนผู้หญิงก็คิด topic ไปแล้ว
ใช่ไหมอ่ะเดี๋ยวจะคุยกับคุณอีกเรื่องนี้
นะแต่พอตื่นเช้ามา
เมื่อคืนคิดไว้ว่าจะคุยอะไรกับคุณอีกนะ
ตอนเนี้ยกูหญิงเนี่ยมีสมุดนะคะคุณนิคมี
สมุดแล้วก็คิดอันจดไว้ก่อนไม่งั้นลืมคน
นี้ก็โจทย์แต่คนนี้น่าจะใส่โทรศัพท์เพราะ
ถ้าคุณอิ๊กมีสมุดนะคุณนิกะห์ไม่ดี 1
อย่างคือคุณนี้ก็จะชอบวางของไว้แล้วก็ลืม
ใช่ก็ถ้ามีสมุดก็ไม่ช่วยเพราะเชียรไว้
แล้วก็ Smooth  out วันนี้
ผู้เขียนจดไว้อยู่ในอยู่ในครัวเราสมุย
เจ้าทิ้งไว้ในครัวพอมาถึงห้องทำงานแล้วก็
เอาสมุดหายไปไหนลืมมันอย่างนี้คุณนี้ก็จะ
ชอบวางของแบบเละเทะวางแล้วก็จำไม่ได้
นะก็โทรศัพท์เนี่ยเราจะไม่ลืมมันติดตัว
ตลอดเวลาใช่ใช่อีกอย่างที่คุณนี่ก็ลืม
บ่อยมากเมื่อก่อนนะตอนอยู่ที่ไทยที่
กรุงเทพนะคือลืมกุญแจบ้านค่ะฮะแล้วคุณนี้
ออกจากบ้านไม่ต้องล็อคบ้านหรอไม่คือลืม
กุญแจบ้านอยู่ในบ้านนี่แหละ
คือบ้านปูนอีกเนี่ยเหมือนก็คุณนี้ก็จะจะ
ชินล็อคกุญแจบ้านทุกครั้งล็อคขึ้นจะเป็น
แม่กุญแจพอมันไม่ต้องใช้กุญแจในการล็อค
เออคือพ่อเป็นแม่กุญแจที่มันต้องมีใคร
หรือเปล่าคุณนิก้าก็จะชอบวางกุญแจไว้ที่
นั่นที่เราลืมเวลาแล้วจะเป็นบ่อยมากเวลา
ที่จะต้องนัดไปเจอเพื่อนหรือออกไปทำงาน
คุณนิดจะบับกุญแจอยู่ไหนออกจากบ้านไม่ได้
ว่าหากุญแจล็อคบ้านไม่ได้ไม่ใช่แล้วก็จะ
เป็นบ่อยมากแล้วมันก็จะใช้เวลาประมาณ
5-10 นาทีหาคุณแจบ้าน
แล้วเวลาเรารีบอะเราก็จะแบบยิ่งลึกไม่
เจอแล้วพ่อหลายครั้งมากที่คุณนี้ก็เจอกด
ดันนิดหน่อยเวลาเรียก grap แล้วกลับมามา
จอดหน้าบ้านแล้วเขาก็ไปเรายังไม่ได้ล็อค
กุญแจบ้านเลยเอาก็ได้กุญแจบ้านอยู่ที่ไหน
ออกจากบ้านไม่ได้เนี่ยหลักจะจะทำยังไง
กุญแจก็วิ่งขาไม่เจอใช่เธอคนนี้ก็จะเป็น
แบบนั้นบ่อยบ่เคยนะ 1 ครั้งคือ
บ้านคูณอีกนะมันจะมีประตู 2 ชั้นก็คือ
ประตูที่มันเปิดแล้วเข้าบ้านแล้วก็ประตู
ใหญ่เนาะอ่ะคนนี้ก็จะออกไปข้างนอกแต่ว่า
ว่าหาคุณแจประตูใหญ่นะไม่เจอเรารีบแล้ว
ไม่ทันคุณมีคำยังไงรู้ไหมคุณนี้ทำยังไงคะ
ปีนรั้วประตูใหญ่ออกข้างนอก
แล้วกูละเข้ามาก็คือเป็นเข้ามาแทนคือไม่
กูดีก็ปีนออกแล้วก็โทรบอกแม่ว่าขอเออ
เนี่ยหากุญแจบ้านไม่เจอยังไงถ้ากลับบ้าน
ตอนกลางคืนก็เปิดประตูบ้านให้หน่อยเพราะ
ว่าจะปีนเข้าบ้านตอนกลางคืนก็อาจจะคิดว่า
ขโมยหรือเปล่าได้ใช่เพราะได้แล้วคุณอีก
ต้องโทรบอกแม่ให้ก็เพราะว่าประตูบ้านที่
อีกชั้นหนึ่งเนี่ยมันไม่ได้ล็อคมันไม่ได้
ปีนเขาก็จะได้รู้ว่าอ๋อไม่ใช่ว่าคุณนิด
ลืมแต่ครูนิกะห์หากุญแจบ้านไม่เจอหนึ่ง
คือไม่ได้ลืมล็อคประตูแต่ลืมว่ากุญแจบ้าน
อยู่ที่ไหนนะใช่ใช่มันก็นั่นแหละเนี่ยขี้
ลืมตื่นใจหาอะไรนิดหน่อยเหมือนเราว่าเรา
คิดเยอะไปหรือเปล่าเขาก็เลยลืมช่วงนี้บาง
ทีก็ไม่ค่อยคิดอะไรก็ไม่มันน่าจะไม่มี
อะไรอยู่ในนี้ล่ะ
หรือว่าน่าจะเป็นที่อายุหรือเปล่าเองเรา
อายุมากขึ้นคือ
อะไรนิดหน่อยก็ลืมนะคะแต่ว่าตอนนี้เราไม่
ลืมนะว่ามันหมดเวลาแล้วกดเวลาแล้วใช่ๆๆๆ
อันนี้ไม่หรือไม่ลืมไม่ลืมไม่ลืมนะคะแล้ว
ก็เดี๋ยวเราเจอกันจะเอาใหม่ในวีดีโอหน้า
ใช่ไหมคะคุณนี้ใช่ครับไว้เจอกันใหม่
วิดีโอหน้าจริงๆนักเรียนอ่ะมีเรื่องอะไร
ที่แบบลืมเนี่ยก็ก็บอกได้เห็นชายเหมือน
เราหรือเปล่าอะไรนิดหน่อยก็ลืมลืมภาษาไทย
พูดยังไงจำไม่ได้
คิดมักจะไทยนะคะผู้หญิงเขียนยังไงนะ
เออ OK ได้ครับไว้เจอกันใหม่คือหญิงกาศ
หวัดดีค่ะพี่